- For those of you who don't know,
this is Roxy, my Husky.
She's the OG rockstar that helped me
launch my social media career.
- [Newscaster] He has more than 2 million
followers on Instagram.
Talk about a fan club.
- Today I wanna share
a very important story
of something that happened with Roxy.
It's a terrible situation.
As you can tell, she's now a tripod,
a three legged dog, and she's doing well
but this situation
could have been avoided.
And I wanna arm you
with information that
you should know when you
have to make a choice
when your pet gets sick.
Roxy come.
Sit. Good dog.
Good doggie. You good dog.
So to set up the story,
Roxy now lives with my dad.
So he takes care of her vet stuff,
takes her in for checkups.
And Roxy had sort of a bump
growing on her right arm.
And this bump was there for several years.
It may have grown slightly
over the course of those years,
but this bump never bothered her.
So I wasn't too concerned about it
but my dad said, "You know what?
I'm gonna point it out to the
vet on the upcoming visit",
which I thought was a very good idea.
So when they went to go
get this bump checked
out and an overall physical,
they said, you know,
for 12 years old, this
dog is doing very well,
in good health running all the time.
She's so fit.
She's so active.
She looks like an eight
year old dog, but they said
we want to take a sample
of the bump on her leg
and send it for cytology,
which means that under a
microscope, they look at
and see what cells are there to decide
is this a cancerous lump,
Non-cancerous lump, et cetera.
So after my dad went,
he gave my phone number
for the vet to call back.
And then when the vet
ended up calling me back,
they said "That unfortunately
the cytology came back
and it looks like this
is a cancerous bump."
They called it a sarcoma
which means that it's
a soft tissue cancer.
And they recommended
bringing the dog back in
for a consultation with the surgeon.
I know how surgery is difficult on humans.
And I could only imagine
how difficult it is
on dogs who need activity
in order to stay fit,
in order to stay mentally well,
especially dogs like Roxy.
She's so active.
She's a Husky.
She has so much energy in her.
So I told my dad a list
of questions that I wanted
him to ask the surgeon.
And those questions are questions
that you should always ask
before going up for a procedure.
A, is this type of cancer that
Roxy has dangerous in that
is it likely to spread?
Is it likely to cause problems
elsewhere in her body?
What's the five year survival rate?
What impact will this have on
her life as a 12 year old dog?
Is it worth for a 12 year
old Husky to go for a surgery
on her leg to remove a
tumor that so far has yet
to cause a problem?
And I thought my dad being a
physician would be well armed
to ask these questions and
I trusted him to do so.
I actually don't talk
to him the following day
when he actually went
for the visit.
And the next day he sends me
me a picture of Roxy
wearing a cast healing
up in the sun, in the backyard.
And I thought, "Oh wow,
she must be doing so much
better because she's healing."
And he goes, "She's doing awesome post-op.
The doctor told me that
it wouldn't be that big
of a procedure and that they
could likely do this, you know,
in and out one day's time.
And they thought it was beneficial."
I was a little bit skeptical,
but you know, seeing the fact
that she was recovering
was very promising to me.
So over the next few days,
things started to change.
She had to go in
for multiple wound checks
to get her wound examined
because the area where she had the tumor,
she had a very thick bandage on,
my dad couldn't check it himself.
There were sutures in
place, staples in place
and they needed to constantly check this.
So she was on antibiotics.
They were doing these checks.
I noticed that the bandage was
on really tight, but you know, I'm looking
at pictures and I'm trusting
my dad and all this stuff.
And then like a week goes
by and my dad calls me
while I'm working in
the hospital and says,
"Mike, I need you to come home
after the hospital and look at Roxy's leg.
I don't think it's good."
And I'm like, "But wait,
like, I'm not a surgeon, A.
I'm not a vet B.
If you think it's bad,
that that means probably
we should go get it checked
out at the vet.
And he was like, "No, I
have an appointment with him
like in two days, I'm gonna go then,
that's when the surgeon is there,
'cause he's on vacation."
You know, some complicated things,
so I said "Of course I'll come by."
So when I came by, I'm
looking at Roxy's foot,
it was now unwrapped and
this is a graphic photo
but I'm gonna show it.
Her foot was dead.
Her paw was dead. Like
there was no blood flow.
It was a cold foot.
It smelled gangrenous,
which means it was becoming infected.
I was like, 'Dad, like, this is terrible.
Like she's gonna lose her foot.
Like there's no, like
this foot has clearly not
had circulation for a
long period of time."
And for me at what I wasn't
sure of was this an issue
of the bandage being very
tight or was this more
of an issue surgically that
when they removed the tumor
they also took out extra tissue
and possibly the blood vessels
that go down to her foot.
And my dad like never clarified this
with the surgeon, Roxy leave it.
So I was very like upset about that
and wondering the whole
time A, should have Roxy
have gotten the surgery, B,
did the surgeon make a mistake?
C, was the bandage on too tight?
And honestly, it's really hard to know
so that when my dad actually went in there
they basically said,
"Yeah, look, we think we should amputate."
And my dad, let me speak to the surgeon.
And I asked the surgeon,
very frankly, like,
"Look, is this a mess up?
Did we take out too much, you know,
tissue that the blood vessel
came out along with it?"
'Cause if you take out the arteries,
and the blood vessels
that are higher in the leg
they essentially feed circulation
to the bottom of the paw.
It would never heal the
bottom of the paw then.
Or was it that the
bandage was on too tight
and the rehab process,
or is she an older dog,
and this is a normal complication
that happens time to time?
And he basically said "All of the above."
And while I appreciate the
honesty, because he said,
"Look, we had to take out a lot of tissue.
The tumor was larger than we expected."
I think like if I was
working with a human surgeon,
I think that we would've
thought about those risks,
that if we open up,
or are potentially getting
ready to open up a person's body
and then we see that we
can cause more damage
than actually benefit by doing
a biopsy or removing a tumor.
We actually don't do it.
So I asked the surgeon,
like "What was the dog's
staging of the cancer?"
And it was a stage one sarcoma.
And not to say that this isn't serious,
it's just at a 12 years
old Roxy's life expectancy
is maybe another two years.
She's getting in that range.
It's sad to say obviously, but you know,
we're really hurting her quality of life
by putting her under the
stress of that surgery,
plus the risk of the things
going wrong, like right now.
So poor Roxy in recovering
from the surgery was
barely able to walk, was
very sick during that time.
And then now we're saying we
have to amputate her entire leg
and not just the entire
leg, the scapula as well,
because apparently dogs,
this is the way to do it.
I asked about a prosthetic, but he said
that that would require a
second operation as well.
And she would have to learn to use it
and an older dog and being a Husky
which is a breed that tends
to be more picky with pain,
He said "That she might
not even adapt well to it."
He recommended just
taking off the entire leg
and kind of told me some new
information that I didn't know
about dogs, that they tend
to handle amputations better
than humans, because they
don't have the psychological,
traumatic component of this,
where they don't miss
having the fourth leg.
That you know, she's like,
'Okay, I have three legs.
This is what I do.
And that's who I am.
And that's the dog I am.
And I move forward."
Can I get a high five?
Where's that messed up task.
- Oh, good girl.
- Wow
- Good girl.
Here you get bonus.
And because of that, they
seem to rebound quite well.
And I will say outta this whole process
that's probably been the
most accurate part of it,
that Roxy has recovered quite well.
Thank God.
She had a mean scar.
You can't really see it now,
but it's healed up quite well.
We took out the staples a few weeks ago.
She's now going for
longer walks with my dad.
When I come home, she's wagging her tail.
She's still shedding like
a monster as you can tell
from all of my clothes,
she's still super sweet.
She's happy, obviously
slightly lower energy
'cause she fatigues.
And now I know she has higher risks
of getting arthritis in her
legs because she's unbalanced.
She has to put more stress
on each one of the joints.
Yeah. It's sad.
It's sad watching, you know,
your dog gets sick with
whatever condition it is.
So all in all this goes to say, you know
when you bring your dog to the vet,
make sure you're armed
with good information.
Make sure you ask hard questions
of both not only the general
vet, but the surgeon.
Make sure they give you
accurate risk assessments
because it's very easy to say,
"Oh, we'll just take this out.
Easy peasy, no problem."
But then like your dog can lose a limb
and it could be quite frustrating
because it feels like you
didn't get all the information
but know that pets are sadly not immortal.
And you want to think
about their quality of
life just as importantly
as you do the length of their life.
So hopefully Roxy continues
to be a little rock star
that she is.
She loves her treats.
And I'm really glad that you know,
this terrible situation kind
of had not the worst ending.
(soft peaceful music)